[Music]
it must be
it must be long
so how long have you two been seeing
each other we've been in a serious
committed relationship for as long as I
can remember we're basically a
relationship experts how did you two
meet
you tell them butter no you tell them
okay well it was really romantic
[Applause]
Wow
that sounds so romantic yeah well we're
soul mates
Oh mate please soul mates I didn't know
food heads well of course food has souls
what do you think it's happening when
you eat food and then you fart that's
their souls escaping okay how do you
know that you're soul mates oh that's
easy
there's so many ways we know for one we
can tell each other anything um you know
I've I've never told anyone this what
never mind I'm too embarrassed tell me
oh okay
Oh someday I dream of becoming a
cinnamon toast
that that's your biggest secret I know
I'm I'm very brave I guess but I trust
you so much I'm just just gonna look
through your facebook real fast okay no
big deal just look around
well it's this what this is why is your
armor on them oh my god oh my goodness
and freaking out I thought we were
exclusive that's my cousin oh oh yeah
could I do that
[Music]
[Music]
okay oh do you think I look okay in this
I think you look like the most beautiful
piece of avocado toes in all of Brooklyn
oh I don't look too much like a hipster
I'm just worried I look like an
overpriced brunch brunch I don't know if
I could do this you'll be fine you've
got this oh I'm nervous I believe in you
it's so freaking hot just get in the
damn toaster okay I'm getting in Oh get
it oh yeah told you it's like warm it's
like a like a one hungry me it's so good
one more episode oh we've already
watched like 50 my eyes are all drive
yeah you're right okay one more episode
I have to know what happens it's crazy
Oh
it'll be over slow down today I sent the
humor is like super in sync
butter is hilarious wait are you trying
to butter me up
you're like Gallagher yeah yeah pretty
much we're food right
[Applause]
but what if you die first oh yeah I'm
pretty sure I die first I fall a lot but
but I can't live without you
fine well let's just die at the same
time oh that's a good idea but
and that's all you need to know about
love yeah when you found the one you
just go mm-hmm butter and toast but got
too much butter hey why do you say there
what do you mean you know cholesterol
[Music]